I am Daniel Desjardins, I'm Brian Bluin And I am a scout master. We threw four, two, six in london,
there in new hamshire, And I am a cub master with pack three, two, eight, five out of rockford,
michigan. This edition of the scout master podcast is sponsored by backers like us. And now for you,
scout master, Here's a little known bit of scouting history And it turns out it's also
a little known piece of baseball history that I recently discovered, just after I made it up.
The Bambino- Yes, Babe Ruth- was a scout master And he often took his scouts camping in the
Great Smoky Mountains And he did this so they could pitch their tents high and outside. Oh yeah,
come on now I put that one right over the plate. Hey, this is podcast number 259.. Hey,
Welcome back to the scout master podcast. This is Clark Green. Wow, let's see here. Let's take a
look in the mail bag. We got some messages here. Liberty Bill left a five star review of the
scout master podcast on iTunes. Thank you so much, Bill. He's a new scout master,
relatively new scout master, working towards a scout led troop, as are many of you,
And we always appreciate reviews. So you can review the podcast on iTunes or on Google Play
And you know you can review the books on Amazon. Certainly do appreciate it when folks go to
the trouble of doing that. Richard Withkowski is with troop 117 in Coatesville, Pennsylvania,
And Richard was on one of our recent chats. We'll talk a little bit more about that in a
moment. He said thanks for all you do. We love the podcast and all the support you give
scouts like us And you know Richard's right up the road for me in a troop that I have known
for many, many years- Troop 117 up there in Coatesville- So it's great to make a connection
there. Tyson got in touch and said: I'm on our district training committee And I was wondering
if I could use your merit badge blue card infographic to print out and distribute during
training. And, Tyson, you can certainly do that. This is a question I get very often
And I like to mention on the podcast. please use anything that we've created to further
the cause of scouting. where you are, Go right ahead and do it. All's we ask is that you'll
let people know where you found the resource. I mentioned our live chat. We had a two or
three live chat sessions this past week. These usually happened during weekday mornings.
You'll see an announcement in our Twitter feed and our Facebook feed that the live chat
feature is is up on scoutmastercgcom. Come along and join us amongst all of our frequent
flyers that check in. We had some new folks check in this week. Zach Guerra is in Los
Angeles where he's an assistant scout master for Troop 716.. Valerie Gibson in
Ingenberg is a chartered org representation Representation is a chartered org representative
in the Sagamore Council of Indiana. Scott Schaefer is in Des Moines, Iowa, where he's a scout
master and a cub master. Matt Bearman is with Troop 971 and PAC 3971 in West Branch,
Mississippi. Vince Hurley is a scout master with Troop 73 in Indianapolis, Indiana,
And David Varyspey is an assistant scout master with Troop 1776 in San Ramon, California. All
those folks checked in on the live chat Once again weekday mornings. Watch the Facebook and
Twitter feeds for an announcement that there's a live chat and the times and come on in and
join us. It's great fun. If you are a regular reader and listener and if the resources that
we've created at ScoutMasterCGcom have helped you, you can return the favor by becoming a
scoutmastercgcom backer. The funds we get from backers go towards the expenses of producing
and publishing the blog posts and the podcasts and the videos and keeping all those resources
accessible to scouts all over the world- and for freely accessible, I may add. It's an easy
thing to do: Go to scoutmastercgcom and click the support link at the top of the page, right
there in the top menu, and you can choose any level of support, and some of those entitle you to
premiums, like autograph copies of my books. So I want to take a moment to personally thank
Raul Aracida, Buddy Broils and Rob Painter, who became backer since our last podcast.
One more time: go to scoutmastercgcom, become a backer this week, and I'll be sure to thank
you personally during our next podcast. Let's see a couple other bits of business to take
care of here In 2016. we've got a great trip to Condersteg International Scout Center scheduled
in July of 2016 and we'd love to have you come along. Go to scoutmastercgcom to check that out
and I'll have a link to the trip details in the post that contains this podcast. and I want to
tell you that this past Thursday night, I was invited by a listener and reader, Bill Chapman,
to lead a Boy Scout leader breakout session at the Saddleback District Roundtable in Lake
Forest, California. It all turned out well. I did not travel to Lake Forest. I was speaking to them
over Skype and we had a great time. I started out by introducing the idea of the patrol method.
We were basically looking at a self-assessment tool I created a few years ago. that's really
just a way to start sparking discussions about the patrol method. If you haven't seen it and
you're interested in it, I'll link to it in the post that contains this podcast. But we introduced that
and we talked about it a little bit and then we opened the floor for questions and thank goodness
people had questions and I just didn't have to drone on and on and do a lecture, you know,
and I want to thank Gary and Nancy and Lori and Carolyn and the others who asked questions
during that session. I mentioned this for a couple of reasons. First of all, I wanted to
thank Bill Chapman, who set up the session and made it happen, and you know we had a pretty good
time doing it. It seemed to be pretty useful and if it's helpful to you to have me come to your
round table that way, I'd certainly welcome the opportunity. so get in touch and let me know
and we'll sort out how to make it happen. One of the other reasons I wanted to mention this was
many. the answers that I had to the questions that were asked during that session were aimed
at listening to Scouts, and I want to expand a little bit on that in this podcast. In Scout
Mastership in seven minutes or less, which is probably going to go a little bit more than seven
minutes because you know that's the way it works- I want to talk about listening to Scouts and then
we've also got just a couple of quick email questions to answer, so that's going to take up
the remainder of the podcast. Let's get started then, shall we Scout Mastership in seven minutes or less?
So, as I said earlier, I was leading a roundtable discussion and, as I shared, many of my answers to
the questions in that discussion were, in short, listen to your Scouts. And, serendipitously, this week's
installment of BP's blog, Baden Powell's blog, features some thoughts from our founder, Sir
Robert Baden Powell, on the subject of listening, and it's from an article in BP's Outlook, which is
a collection of pieces that he wrote for the Scouter magazine, and this particular piece
that I shared this week on BP's blog was written in 1922 and it's titled appropriately:
Listen- Just a very good one word title. And in this article BP encouraged Scoutsers
to consider listening rather than talking as the most effective tool to work with Scouts.
In this article he said several things. He said that a Scout Master can save his brains
by using his ears and to listen to what his boys are talking about and keep his own mouth shut.
Here's a great allegory he used in the article. He said: when in wartime a soldier scout is out
at night and wants to gain information of the enemy's moves, he does so to a large extent
by listening. Similarly, when a Scout Master is in the dark as to the inclination or the
character of his boys, he can to a great extent get it by listening. In listening, he will gain
a close insight into the character of each boy and a realization of the way in which he can best
be interested. If Baden Powell went on to say: you make listening an observation your particular
occupation, you will gain much more information from your Scouts than you can put into them
by your own talk. Find out from them, by listening or questioning, which activities appeal most to them
and see how far you can get these going. So too, in giving instruction, it is better by far
to get your boys to debate a point or to ask you questions than to preach information to them.
There's a lot to be got by listening and observing. So, with Bin Powell's advice in mind,
let's talk about the idea of Socratic Scouting. Now, if you're not familiar with this Socratic
Method, here's a great introduction that comes from the 1973 movie The Paper Chase, directed by
James Bridges. In this little excerpt here, Professor Kingsfield is being played by actor John
Hausman, and he is making his introduction to his course at Harvard Law School in the movie.
So listen to this. We use the Socratic Method here. I call on you: I'll ask you a question
and you answer it. Why don't I just give you a lecture? because through my questions you learn
to teach yourselves. Through this method of questioning, answering, questioning, answering.
we seek to develop in you the ability to analyze that vast complex of facts
that constitute the relationships of members within a given society.
Questioning and answering: At times you may feel that you have found the correct answer.
I assure you that this is a total delusion on your part. You will never find the correct,
absolute and final answer. In my classroom there is always another question, Another
question to follow your answer. As you're on a treadmill, my little questions spin the
tumblers of your mind. You're on an operating table. My little questions are the fingers
probing your brain? You do brain surgery here. You teach yourselves the law,
but I train your mind. You come in here with a skull full of mush
and you leave thinking like a lawyer. I remember hearing this years and years and years ago
and it really made a big impression on me. That's Socratic Method: Listening, asking
questions, hearing the answers and asking more questions is really just this wonderful,
practical and versatile tool for Scouters. It's a tool we can apply to developing youth leaders,
to instruction, to training, to counseling, to mentoring, and it's an incredibly powerful way
for us to achieve the aims of Scouting. Using Socratic Scouting, We're really teaching Scouts
the crucial skill of learning how to learn, by appealing to their national inquisitiveness
and inspiring them to work things out for themselves. I've also seen this method called
Guided Discovery, and Guided Discovery is not making statements or lecturing, but asking questions
that encourage Scouts to figure things out. In the roundtable discussion that I mentioned
earlier, there was a lot of talk about how patrols are arranged or how you make
certain decisions about the way Scouts are going to do things, and my continuous
encouragement to everybody was: well you know, sit down and talk to the patrol leaders.
sit down and talk to your senior patrol leaders. sit down and talk to the patrol leaders council.
ask them how they think they're going to solve this. You already have a solution,
you already have a strategy and you could just tell them what to do. but the real magic
moment in Scouting is when we get into this Socratic Method and we start asking them questions
and they can come up with some amazing things. They can come up with some amazing strategies
and plans and answers on their own if we're listening to their answers. Now, if we lecture Scouts,
we echo what they have done in school a thousand times and I think a lot of times they react
accordingly. Their attentiveness is going to be brief. they'll show little appreciation or
understanding for what's being said and they'll retain very little of what we're offering
because they just kind of switch goes off and they say: an adult is speaking now
and well, you know, I'll listen. I guess. yep, this is what adults say all the time. I've heard it a
hundred times. I wonder if anybody's texted me recently, you know what I mean. so let's remember:
Scouting promises engaging, active things, not sitting and listening. who can blame Scouts,
who come to Scouting with this promise of engagement and activity and they find themselves
in another classroom situation and they feel a little bit like they've been cheated out of
something. This Socratic Scouting, or Guided Discovery, transforms the role of the Scout
from a passive learner to an active participant in what's going on. One question follows another,
like a path of breadcrumbs, just like we heard Professor Kingsfield saying-
and then the Scouts discover what they need to know, and when they discover things this way, the
light comes on, so it's almost a physical phenomena. they brighten up. more than just learning the
right answers to things or learning how to do something they have learned for themselves.
they've learned to seek these things out and teach themselves. so suppose we want our Scouts to
learn how to safely handle and maintain a pocket knife. it's a pretty common thing, right?
well, we could sit them down and talk to them and we could explain everything to them.
or we could lay out some pocket knives and things on the table and we could, and we could engage them
in this Socratic Scouting method, right? what are the things on this table? well, some pocket knives
and stuff. well, how do you use them? how can you find out how they're used. why isn't important?
we learn to use them correctly. and one question leads to the next. Scouts are actively involved
in supplying the answers, rather than simply recording information. they're going to pick up
the knives, they're going to use them and they learn more with their hands than with their ears.
so we make sure they start working with their hands right away. we move away from the table
in a very few minutes and the Scouts start practicing and trying out things they've
discovered. they can coach each other in these skills and ask us questions. they're active and
engaged and happy and, as I said before, Socratic Scouting right. the, the guided discovery methods
are not limited to instruction. we can employ it to counsel and to train and to mentor our Scouts.
so when we're talking with the Patrol Leaders Council, what do you think? what's your plan
for handling this particular thing? what should we do next? how are you going to go about doing that?
can you explain it to me in very simple, step-by-step method, how exactly you're going to do that? when
we're sitting down and having a scout master's conference and we're looking at things like
scout spirit and participation and things like that, how about we ask the scout about it instead of
substituting our own judgment for theirs? how about we call upon that developing standard
of the scout oath and law inside them and say: well, you know what, I have my own opinions
about scout spirit, but I'm much more interested in hearing yours. why don't you tell me what you
think it means? why don't you tell me if you think you fulfilled this requirement? and once we start
doing that, we're just unlocking all these many doors and we're really working at achieving
the aims of scouting, which is the development of character right. so once we get the hang of guiding
and discovery and we use this Socratic Scouting method rather than preaching or teaching or
lecturing, we'll find that it's one of the most useful tools in your kit. it'll make your scouts
engaged and active and it will advance the aims of scouting.
so-
and here's an answer to one of your emails-
Hey, just a couple of quick email questions. this week
Rick Williamson uh got in touch. he says I'm a new scout master for troop 131 in Scottsdale, Arizona.
I listened to your podcast. the information you provide has helped me. uh. recently a scout
brought me three completed blue cards from a merit badge clinic. the guide to advancement
requires that a scout talk to the unit leader for approval before the scout starts working
with a merit badge counselor. the blue cards that I received from the merit badge clinic
from three different merit badge counselors were issued without having my signature on them first,
indicating that I'd spoke them with the scout. now I don't think we should penalize the scout
for the error that these merit badge counselors made, but I don't exactly know what to do next.
well, Rick, thanks for listening and thanks for getting in touch. this is an easy question
because it's not my opinion. it's all spelled out very clearly in the guide to advancement.
you're correct in that we wouldn't ever want to ding a scout for something they can't control,
and the way that the counselors handle this is not strictly as they should have. we're not
going to make the scouts suffer because the counselor didn't understand something. what we want
to do in a situation like this is to get in touch with the counselor district advancement
committee, because these are the folks who approve merit badge counselors and we want to let them know
what happened, and it's up to them to tell the counselors in question that they may have
made a mistake by accepting a blue card without a unit leader's signature, or to explain to you
why that wasn't required in this particular situation. they may have set something up for
a merit badge clinic or something. I really don't know now. this is a pretty common thing
where people have concerns about the way merit badges are being cancelled.
so there's a form in the guide to advancement 2013. I'll have a link to the guide. uh, you'll
find the form. it's called reporting merit badge counseling concerns on page 81 of the guide,
and that's a way to keep the people who are registering merit badge counselors aware. if
there are any concerns or problems, and they'll they'll, they'll make sure to correct them.
I had this email from Kathy, who asked who else other than the scout master can conduct scout
master conferences. well, Kathy, that's a really good question and all of the resources I've checked.
so that's the scout master's handbook and and things like that describe the conferences
between the scout master or the unit leader and the scout. there is no specific prohibition
about others conducting the conference, but it is called a scout master conference and I wouldn't
advise anyone but the scout master conduct that conference. in the guide to advancement, it will
talk about the unit leader because- and that includes scout masters and and varsity scouting
leaders and and for venturers too, but it's very specific that it is the unit leader and while
there is no, like I said, express prohibition against it, it is pretty clear exactly what's intended there.
so, Kathy, I hope that helps. hey, if you have a question, you'd like to get in touch with me?
it's pretty easy to do and I'd love to hear from you. so you're going to find out how to get in
touch in just a moment. well, thank you for listening to this 259th edition of the scout master
podcast. here's how to keep in touch. read the blog at scoutmastercgcom and, while you're there, you can
subscribe to updates to the blog by email. you can join about 4 000 other mobile scouts who have the
scout master app on their mobile devices, and if you're in the android tribe, you can go to google
play and get the app, and if you're in the apple tribe, you can go to iTunes and get the app.
you can also experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom in the vast panorama of social media.
join the 8100 folks who like scoutmaster blog on Facebook. tweet along with the chorus of 1200
tweeters on twitter. pin the poultry to his pictures proffered publicly, with 1900 other prolific
pinners on Pinterest. watch us at scoutmastercg on youtube or join the 400 odd folks who form
the exclusive scoutmastercg circle on google plus. now, if you can't face facebook, if twitter
makes you bitter, if you've no interest in pinterest, if you don't put the? u in youtube, if you're a minus
when it comes to google plus, that's all right. bunkie, just zoom into the late 90s and send me an
email. you can get in touch with me. clark green, with your comments and questions and wild ideas
at clark at scoutmastercgcom. c, l, a, r, k, e at scoutmastercgcom. all that remains is for me to
remind you that the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast are not official publications of
the Boy Scouts of America, or nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America or any
other scouting organization in existence for that matter, because i am sure they have much
better things to do with their time. it's just me talking into a microphone, trying to lend a hand
to scout leaders and have a little bit of fun along the way. and speaking of fun, here he is our
august founder, sir robert bedan. pal, sir robert, good luck to you and good camping. oh why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.